[Musique]
nous sommes en 1954 dans un petit
village de la haute vallée de la loue
ne vous y trompez pas si on fait les
vendanges c'est un peu pour conjurer le
sort
le vignoble est à l'agonie depuis près
d'un demi siècle
le phylloxéra les deux guerres
l'industrie ont contribué à décimer les
vignes ancestrales
[Musique]
cet homme au nez de clown s'appelle
charles lui c'est mon grand père il
partageait avec les enfants ce monde
imaginaire qui laisse libre cours aux
rêves
son rêve à lui était de redonner la vie
au vignoble et au verger de la vallée
lors des dernières années de sa vie je
me souviens il prenait le train pour
paris avec dans son cabas quelques
bouteilles de sa production
ils voulaient persuader les autorités
ministérielles de la capitale de ne pas
laisser mourir sa vallée on le disait
fou utopiste on riait de lui et pourtant
quelques-uns de ces gamins en culottes
courtes
trente ans plus tard réalise sont réels
[Musique]
relancer la vigne
le vieux charles aurait aimé vivre cette
aventure
peut-être par fidélité ou complicité
je commence à filmer cette aventure nous
sommes en 2005 le nouveau vignoble à
bientôt 20 ans et la balle et semble
avoir retrouvé son image perdu
ouais ça lui est là
[Musique]
depuis toujours j'ai jamais imaginé
habiter ailleurs qu'ici jamais quitté
vraiment aller
[Musique]
tous les gens qui avaient à l'époque une
trentaine d'années ont dit on va décider
de rester là et puis on va faire quelque
chose pour notre pays et quand même pas
laisser tomber en ruine donc c'est lui
arrivait assez insoupçonnées on a pris
conscience d'environnement de
l'enfrichement et alors il fallait
trouver les solutions
mon père d'une petite vigne donc je
savais je savais que ça pouvait marcher
après on en a pris on a pris des
conseils ici ou là on a fait le 9e de
visite
on s'est lancé quoi on a créé rues
ranimant 84 qui est l'abréviation
d'associations pour le animations à
développement rural d'anla autour de
l'eau on a fait un budget qu'il fallait
quand même dès le départ quand même
avait été invité bien et bien pensé
quand même on n'est jamais partout
lafleur lui quand même faut pas non plus
exagérer
notre but c'était plutôt d' associer le
maximum de gens donc on a voulu
continuer dans le milieu associatif et
on a fait un appel au peuple avec des
actions l'époque de 500 francs
l'objectif c'était quand même de
commande installé un couple de vignerons
qui soit capable de prendre en charge
l'ensemble d'instruction puis de la
vinification et la gestion de tout et
c'est l'objectif de départ c'était un
projet fou de la relance du vignoble je
les prie vraiment à mon compte je les
fais avec passion la création du
vignoble c'est un moment fort de rue en
imsa
[Musique]
bien s'épaissit bonjour non
bon se mentir pas permettre à la france
oh
fillon
il a fait sa tâche salle unique tête
mais là vous êtes mes toiles ferland je
vous ai téléphoné c'était à vous je ne
sais pas je vous ai dit que j'étais
sympathisante met d'accord venir et là
j'ai dit c'est très bien pour nous
donner chacun un sécateur et puis vous
allez rejoindre l'équipe là bas c'est ça
le pire c'est vous parce que couper les
deux mains qui viennent de metz de
strasbourg ii le plus loin donc il faut
bien qu'il nous arrive c'est des gens
qui sont ils sont salariés qui
travaillent donc j'ai mon travail à lyon
est
pagé les réunions toute la semaine c'est
bien dommage quoi va avoir du mal à
tenir en oublier mais ça va pas être
facile dans les années à venir voir
qu'on voit un petit peu ici on peut
retrouver des bénévoles presque bon il
commence un peu à vieillir justement
l'amour de la terre s'était pas aussi
prononcée maintenant qu'avant 60 pas
avoir des salariés c'est pas de salarié
du produit le cadre de la le cadre de
l'entreprise puisque c'est bien que ce
soit une association c'est une véritable
entreprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu défends seront là c'est moi là tu
compte que dans ton grand hockey table à
renier là vous avez travaillé là où je
vais chez ma mère travaille et tous les
gens qui viennent qui passe là-bas
odinga est superbe elle a compris qu'il
trouve quand même oui oui c'est tout
les cueilleurs bénévoles ont quitté la
vallée je vais rester au village car
c'est désormais au chai que l'histoire
deux heures à nîmes se poursuit
la c1 semble c'est observons à charge
mais non c'est vous dire ça fait un
congrès
apparemment ça s'équilibre et le sud
domine pas je crois que tu vas faire un
bel oxymore sonné le jour la fin de
l'année approche
nous quittons la vallée pour nous rendre
sur le plateau j'accompagne le vigneron
au marché de noël
[Musique]
là les bras trop bouteilles pour les
quoi à blanc et rouge
tremblant
[Musique]
comme ça plus deux comme ça
moi je veux faire de a à z
donc c'est ça que moi je voudrais
arriver à fait être l'exploitant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
terminera aux médias
ce dernier a retiré des fonds à partir
et attend sa facture et la police
'les deux journaux voient non tout ça il
ya tout détacher c'est pareil mais pour
au pay et j'ai fait 600 euros
une après-midi au payer il ya 2500 ans
voyez on ap
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'iaaf a enseigné l'histoire c'était la
balade dominicale de lait par an comme
j'étais petit le hasard a fait que je
décide à chercher des chaumes maison
j'ai trouvé c'est là où j'habite et là
où je suis heureux
[Musique]
cette année libre de tout engagement
professionnel je me suis investi un
petit peu dans rue ranime de plus en
plus et puis j'ai pris une carte au club
du troisième âge pour pour parfaire un
peu cette intégration
[Musique]
le secrétariat c'est pas mon métier mais
je suis imprégné de
du besoin des changes avec les gens pour
les connaître pour mieux faire connaître
par sentiment que s'il ya aussi un peu
de sentiments jamais j'aime bien j'aime
bien les gens si vous allez sur le site
internet vous avez un bon de commande
que vous pouvez remplir ça facilite les
choses
d'abord l'homme est bon
vous avez vous même
c'est tout et n'importe quoi
l'agencement à définir tous les
tous les tous les ans il ya des volontés
de changement
il ya des volontés certainement de
stagnation de roubles et même de gagner
mais fatigués les lanières fonctionne
depuis qu alors être les mêmes personnes
avec bonheur
et puis là maintenant et tout le monde
me fatigue pas de si on peut ressusciter
à plat quelques uns
une envie de travailler d'avoir des nous
un peu de notre gueule comme la mienne
ils connaissent le dos à la clinique qui
sont aussi sont rentrés de ses biens
c'est comme ça que ça repartira mais un
seul bonhomme c'est zéro
au fil des heures
j'observe denis et gérard
[Musique]
la distillation est un moment privilégié
et qui leur permet d'échanger leur
savoir et d'exprimer leurs inquiétudes
au niveau des fixations du des prix de
prix qui court et trop qui
correspondrait mieux à notre situation
le premier soulagement on a délégué le
temps s'écoule lentement et la parole se
libère j'ai vendu c'est une deuxième
angoisse qui fuient la première il
semble que rue ranime amorce une période
où la troisième si j'ai peur de ne pas
être de passage n'ont plus qu'à user ses
les façons offert ses causes y trouver
d'autres sources de marché c'est aussi
le temps de le travailler autrement
la situation est fragile et ici
l'entente que parfaite
il venait de v
avec denis et gérard l'esprit collectif
de rire à nîmes se perpétue le vigneron
et le secrétaire s'initie mutuellement
d'un aux méandres alambiqué de la
gestion et l'autre à l'apprentissage
délicat de la distillation
mais attention quand on distille il faut
aussi savoir jouer avec le feu
permettant d
moi je pense qu'hier on était fatigués
dans l'après midi
c'est peut-être plus tôt on a rien à vue
nous on a respiré vapeur satanique du
menhir et là tu ressors des soucis
kiala
pour la liste la liste qui a pour le
responsable d'exploitation ce qui doit
être capable de faire quatre pages
sports oui je fais un stage le titre
peine responsables espèrent même pour me
salir mon premier jeu pour moi ça s'en
vient d'où je prends les moyens de nos
travers moraux
j'ai pu les moyens d'être responsable de
ce que je suis aujourd'hui mais il
manque des notions pouvoir gérer
l'exploitation comme elle doit être
gérée
il ya une attitude il ya aussi un j'ai
perdu en 15 ans j'ai fait deux
quand j'avais ce que j'avais appris je
travaille plus par habitude que et je
cherche lui violations
[Musique]
passant de tout faire parce que je vous
organise aussi peut-être pas mal mais
j'ai pris pas d'autre moyen de
m'organiser parce que je manquais perso
je trouve pour faire ça il faudrait
avoir les moyens d'embaucher
j'ai beau travailler quand il était à
mon compte pas compter mes heures mais
je suis je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
réagir comme un salarié parce que je ne
suis pas mort au jeu prévu sur wii sait
jamais
pluralisme cherchait un bâtiment qui est
de la lure un bâtiment vide ans parce
qu'il s'agissait pas pour nous de
construire un hangar métallique dans une
zone industrielle
donc on aura un magnifique magasin de
vente 5 avr je souhaiterais
personnellement ce n'est pas l'avis
unanime mais qu'on puisse installer
également une distillerie en finale pour
diversifier un peu nos productions à la
fois utiliser cette série pour notre
production de marquer actuellement
décidé à moutier dans des conditions
difficiles
et puis en même temps participer à la
relance et fruité dans cette vallée dont
tout le monde parle mais personne ne
fait grand chose
l'élément principal de ce nouveau chai
c'est la vente
donc si on veut avoir un avenir
touristique économique profiter de la
clientèle touristique
il faut qu'on puisse recevoir les gens
recevoir des bus comme les dix ou douze
personnes du comité et les partisans de
rester petits seins de rester entre nous
et puis à les partisans d'un
développement ce que la majorité
développement de notre entreprise
puisque c'est le but toutes les
entreprises de se développer
c'est pas un appartement qu'on fait là
c'est et on dit le nouveau chai pour
qu'on arrête avec ce nom c'est pas
lâcher puisque on fera jamais le cheylas
c'est un lieu de stockage un lieu de
commercialisation et c'est pas nous ont
jamais on prévoit les choses je n'ai pas
là justement on aurait dû le prévoir moi
je dis vous détend bien sur mais moi
j'ai moi je bouge en écoutant lundi de
soissons le che il restera à la barre le
fromage et à chaque fois on était les
deux pôles dire et puis maintenant tu
iras en croire en croire qu' alain
humour c'est le problème 2004 2005 c'est
pas évident dans la conjoncture actuelle
donc l'objectif d'un nationale essaie de
mettre à zéro les fonds nécessaires
quand on travaille presque doubler la
vente sur place
moi je vous dit quelque chose aussi
l'achat d'un étiquetage temps on a une
hauteur on peut pas mettre une part et
d'autre ça c'est l'aberration autre
chose c'est tous des petits détails on
en reparlera si tu veux au delà du
bâtiment mais c'est vrai que je ne sais
pas je ne critique pas je critique le
fait qu' on n'a pas être associé à ce
genre de choses des remarques et on l'a
vu ne fait pas chaud en effet dans happy
août contre ou pas ma foi c'est un peu
de voix mais ça c'est tout ça ça serait
bien parce que j'étais comme de l'argent
qui a été investi qu'on commence à faire
les choses sérieusement regarder les
louent leur surface et les plus grandes
de la corde qu'on a
mais l'étiqueteuse est plus grande que
ça il faut que deux mètres carrés un
quinté les plans l'impressionné pas de
place je vais regarder alors peut-être
que toi tu as pris les décisions parce
qu'il fallait les prendre
ça je le bien qu accordé mais on aurait
bon on aurait pu essayer d'en débattre
collectivement au sein du conseil
d'administration
c'est la remarque bon c'est quand même
le nieront qui utilisent les alsh et
enfin une bonne partie des chefs c'est
quand même important que qui se sentent
qu'ils s'y sentent bien
voilà c'est simplement à ce niveau là où
je pense que mon compte a fait confiance
et moi je n'ai pas d'appartement est
parfaitement capable de faire ta
profession
quand on est parfaitement capable de ce
que conçoit un dossier de ce genre ça
permet à moi ce qui me ce qui me
chagrine 1e c'est que le monde soit et
des observations à faire qu'il faut que
tous les arbitres et c'est tout
la preuve du chantier des cages en gerbe
rien je peux et je pense car est arrivé
à ce stade de la discussion ne pourra
pas avancer plus noble alors on nous
propose ce qui sévit date dès maintenant
avec l'afld avait redonné la vie
claudine et puis là le métrage que
propose derniers temps pour mettre les
choses au point et puis tout le monde
ressort de cette fusion d'accord lui
l'essence après tout le long du lido
pamela au poteau la faux je te reverrai
et bientôt ternon prête moi dont on il
est rentré dans la maison sont situés
sur paillasson il a bousculé mon kaboré
s'est emparé d'un tonneau
[Musique]
mais des tonneaux je leur ai donné
j'écoute ont de fait les paquets découpe
en trois jeux des cerceaux vos ben on
prête moi ton tonneaux au niveau de
l'association le vit le vigneron va
partir vous partez pas qui il s'entend
plus avec le dirigeant selon le
président de l'association et c'est lui
qui faisait du bruit 2007 les partis la
taille
et puis les bénévoles venaient l'aider à
faire il fait même pas défendre puis moi
non plus c'est dommage
ces bénévoles qui vous êtes
c'est dommage je finis de relever et
après je me sens libre de l'eau jusqu'au
ciel j'étais soda mais aujourd'hui je
reviendrai de droits humains vitrac en
bronze
il avait dit je reviendrai et effaré
encore vous devenu un homme maintenant
en finale sait jamais ce qui peut trop
vieux
[Musique]
arôme est là mais c'est le chien qui
sociétaires le principal évènement de
actuelle c'est le départ le 13 le 18
août
les deux hommes donc c'est un nouvelle
page d'histoire custom de nus peints et
son épouse sont été et virons de la
fondation le ca que leurs enfants aussi
on le remercie de tout ce qu'il a fait
on our depuis quinze ans n'oublie pas
qu'on a fait on sait plus pourquoi nous
faisons même sens
c'est sa décision
rien de pleurer je suis particulièrement
chagriné de voir partir puisque c'est
moi qui l'avait embauché il ya 15 ans
moi je voudrais quand même que jeune
s'il n'est pas là que l'on puisse vous
faire languir aujourd'hui pour tout ce
qu'il a fait pour eux
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
c'est une crise dans un groupe où il va
falloir surmonter la crise
c'est une crise qui va falloir surmonter
actuellement rien à surmonter mais rien
d'insurmontable mais le corner
il faut rebondir
il faut que l'association se structurent
animaux pour rebondir
voir une formation
je retrouve un mignon
le problème c'est qu'on est d'accord
[Musique]
denis parent sans attendre les vendanges
la nature poursuit son cycle
tout semble si fragile à présent le
serment de charles n'était peut-être
qu'une illusion
[Applaudissements]
thales n'a pas la vie qui vaut mieux
attendre l asie est préférable attend
cet après-midi et mûrissent encore un
peu plus
[Musique]
o o
combien
voit l'étendue tsonga n'aura fait que
moody's ait parlé décembre 7,6 j'ai
pensé annonces de partenaires ouais
parce qu'ils sont bien vus max est pire
aux deux ans à temps pour diminuer le
sucre
oui mais voilà qu de ce coin avignon
c'est comme un cuisinier sur son
fourneau et la d'intuition et l'a initié
reconnaître des arômes il s'est marié il
s'est marié des saveurs et puis la nuit
rumba le levine le vinificateur
exactement eh bien il doit quand même
aussi de ressentir son vin où il en est
ficelle moment opportun de dire stop
c'est maintenant qu'on va apprécier les
rouges parce que j'ai potentiel avec le
départ de dénis et fernand beaucoup de
bénévoles ne sont pas revenus
mais d'autres ont pris la relève cette
année encore les gammes et les
chardonnay et les auxerrois ont bien été
récoltés
ce pilier qui polluent
il est facile assure à nîmes continue
mais comment et jusqu'à temps
[Musique]
non
de nos eaux
[Musique]
e
alors
cassez-vous gounelle merci paris pendant
trois ans
notre place de monde
même ce niveau par un modérateur octobre
mais parce qu elle qui feront quand on
enlève le prix
je rends mon tablier
[Musique]
m
ça se relance bien là avec les jeunes
chauriennes elles animeront tout ça il
ya la nouvelle cave labaye tableau qui
s'occupe d'eux et yves un champ gare de
cerbère partir des bonnes raisons at on
laissé tomber st
on peut pas maintenant la vigne vu que
l'évolution qu'a eue la fatigue piles
huiles denis et doit être est il était
fatigué aussi par maman il a fallu avoir
peut-être quelqu'un pour l'aider plus
sérieusement continuellement mais on
peut pas le payer quoi un chapeau
maintenant ça sera plus pareil qu'avant
c'est fini maintenant serait donc on
aura pu les on ne connaîtra plus du tout
ces bénévoles qui s'ennuient nous a
aidés puissions donner le temps qui
conduit on a un peu l'usure la fatigue
des gens parce que moi je sais bien
qu'il ya des gens qui vont ils pouvaient
plus à l'est un thomas finalement il
faut prier vos billets le soleil a du
mal de moi je suis drôlement content et
cher va la trouver une jeune femme de 25
ans qui va arriver où le décès le 2
janvier voilà pour et par
l'intermédiaire d'internet
il vient de toulouse elle a fait des
stages aux états unis en californie en
australie la branche a appris à les
prochaines repartir l'année d'après en
dessous
et là c'est pareil comme je couve comme
ça après tu voi atteindra 1 2 par
exemple moi je coupe là on fait comme
moi je coupe juste avant du couple
juste avant les gens venaient là où ça
va être dur c est rare et le tracteur
quoi ça sert de se dire que comme c'est
donc ça devient dangereux d'avoir de la
pente de faire attention surtout l autre
acteur après à pied ça se fait on glisse
aux miss mais bon c'est pas le temps de
la pluie c'est magnifique je suis que
les saisons sont marqués les cuirs et
mime et bolt avec le soleil ça énerve
aussi mais je ne sais pas trop
moi je peux pas trop dire un aimant a
été dans un an ou deux je suis porte
bien aussi ça me pose un problème ne
sais pas a priori un de suite je me dis
comment voulez vous c'est quoi c'est que
la fin du monde il ya d'autres gens qui
n'y sont pas morts alors bon c'est que
c'est pas si catastrophique que ça
autre
cette colonne vendredi on a considéré
ministration donc ça s'est un peu kitsch
que tu n as tu as raison mais ce serait
bien de venir les baies que sa
reconnaissance et les jantes en alu on
s'étonnera pas tu faisais tout de suite
par contre pas que ça dégénère tout le
monde a sa part de pouvoir toi tout le
monde dépense d'une façon c'est pas
forcément la même que l'autre donc
c'était au mieux et au patois sol pour
l'instant c'est vrai que j'ai vu gérard
soins qui m'a dit que déjà il s'occupait
aussi des choses à et moi et puis je
pense qu'après le mieux aussi ses
devoirs et louis parce qu'au point de
vue technique administratif
voilà donc bon je pense que les deux
comme ça ça va être migrés le médiateur
moi j'ai très confiance à sa venue
j'espère qu'on va pas louper la faire
parce que si un loupé ça sera ça sera ne
cessera d'où ça sera pas être
est ce que tu te sens identifié à vous
aimer ce que c'est devenu une part de ta
vie est belle oui moi je suis chaud je
suis là trois quarts de temps avez-vous
année d'ailleurs c'est je vais faire et
je vais mettre un petit peu de oh là là
dessus parce que c'est pas c'était pas
le but
j'ai mis le doigt sur le sur le dans
l'engrenage
j'ai passé la main en train d'y passer
le bras je suis pas d'acheter plus
d'accord là je suis plus d'accord
damman dans mon esprit il ya mille sept
cents sociétaires
il ya quatre pelés 5 tendu à vide à
francky qui font tous qui a surtout et
c'est lourd c'est lourd pour tous
le point crucial de rire à nîmes c'est
pour ça que je parlais en préambule
d'une crise profonde
autrement plus graves que celles celle
de du départ de denis qui a toute son
importance mais qui tout ça est lié et
quand quand denis est parti on m'a dit
c'est bon c'est fini je dis non ça
continue ça peut être même que ça
commence seulement c'est certain cette
transformation 7 3 7 transformations
inéluctable de la vie dure à nîmes il
faut passer à une phase de travail
commercial parce qu'on nous vend on peut
rendre le plus qu'on ne le vend
seulement la première des choses c'est
d'arrêter d'investir
on voit encore se charger d'un d'un
alibi qui va coûter 40 mille euros c'est
pas rien financé à 50 % par des
subventions j'en conviens mais il reste
encore vingt mille euros qu'on n'a pas
comment va-t-on faire
après il ya les affaires de benoît la
vasque ce sujet
une année c'est cool gérard a
démissionné de l'association
leslie n'a pas attendu les vendanges et
les parties après 6 mois louis borloo
assure le suivi de la vigne et de la
vinification denis salariés vigneron n'a
toujours pas été remplacé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
je suis parti sans avoir envie de partir
le but de ma démission n'était pas de
partir c'était de réveiller un peu les
gens manque de bol ils ont pas envie se
réveiller donc j'étais obligé de m'en
aller
voilà donc depuis bon ben je vois les
voitures montées ça ça me fait toujours
quelque chose de voir les voitures
montées on est toujours là tiens il ya
un tête à tête qui au centre fait ça me
faisait toujours que ça fait quand même
du mal de savoir que ce sont des autres
qui la font dans l'autre ça c'est la
récolte 2007 à votre santé à bercy
venait au pouvoir
explications
la mutation
pensez vous c'est tout ce que vous voyez
ici toute la végétation vous voyez ici
si on fait tout haut de la vallée la
même même si pied des ruines du château
qu'on voit là toute la vallée d'ici sept
écoles de la ville que naveen que die
linke tallinn que la vie il faut
prévenir ont poussé le front plus haute
que ça il faut que tu as dis pas cela
mais on a toujours ce v là au milieu
c'était cet espace libre rôle au milieu
qui nous permet de sécher très vite les
grappes
voilà qui ar ça nous permet d'avoir
beaucoup moins une pourriture
[Musique]
bonjour à vous faire maintenant
désormais donc on est maintenant en 2008
et 18 ans après l'implantation donc on
peut dire que les gens ne réussit les
deux et dix huit années réussies et
notre pari puisque maintenant
s'appliquera à terre les bénéfices comme
prévu au départ ont été réinvestis dans
les acquisitions des terrains de
l'immobilier et du matériel auprès
d'entreprises vont faire équipe et
performant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
le retour à maintes occasions nous ont
servis quel dommage johnny et les aînés
ainsi pourra toujours nous aider oui oui
[Musique]
un lâcheur doublera pas que le patro
décidemment non pour l'égalisation fait
bien d'accord jacomet voudra et roulant
tac tac tac au siège à cette dépense est
alors vous pouvez dépenser alors avant
ils vont dire des nombreux débouchés
comme soul à un chargeur dit réponse est
facile aurait 50 66 mentions et 50 %
dont on a constaté qu'on pouvait pas
baser uniquement sur le
le réseau associatif et donc il fallut
bien le faire des commerces et une fois
arrivé à un certain chiffre d'affaires
on est obligé de se transformer en
entreprise
on a les règles normales de toute
entreprise ce que beaucoup je n'arrive
pas à comprendre c'est qu'une une
association ela un trésorier un
président alors que une entreprise et
lin directeur et puis un comptable chose
je pense quand même pour des mots
tellement que les problèmes vous n'avez
q depuis trois quatre ans c'est
essentiellement des problèmes de
management voilà jeté les chaudes com de
com de façon moderniste un peu mais
c'est que je pense véritablement avec
des conceptions peut-être différente de
la marche des affaires
c'est un problème d'homme aussi quelques
d'un faux pas sur un faux-pas solaire
c'est un problème d'homme la thèse que
je défendrai début juin c'est une fois
profession fins professionnelles
l'association est de l'asie naissent du
vin et de la gestion il des verbes on
passe un contrat d'un bail de fermage je
peux commencer s'appelle l'intention des
emprunts de sorges
la chambre culture après c'est sûr que
c'est le choix sur le choix de la
personne c'est sûr que alors denis le
nid dans cette affaire ce qu'il faut
qu'ils reviennent
une présidence tout faire n'importe quoi
faut plus demandés si on aime et ce
qu'il a fait si on est d'accord nous
contre il faut mettre leur gloire
l'avenir a proposé des choses on met
donc à l'assemblée générale de
l'association qui m'intéresse et câliner
via skype à la gueule des conflits qu'il
était certain nombre de gens ici se sont
fait l'écho aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faut que chacun donc si effectivement
c'est un vote de défiance ça veut dire
que dans la foulée de le priver de tout
le conseil des missions
moi les paupières 4
[Musique]
la glace il ya une volonté commune de
vouloir tourner la page d'avancé sur
saône et dire ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
explique denis lévesque dit ce que vous
les français vous dit rien vous dire
encore toute la ligne non non je vais je
suis intervenu pour que c'est je crois
la ville en nommant son tenir uni pour
nos balles un sommet troy 77,9 double
[Applaudissements]
nous restons en place je pense que le
conseil l'a compris le message est
envoyé par le l'assemblée générale je
pense qu'il faut changer il faut des
changements certainement une affaire qui
fait un chiffre d'affaires de combien
deux cent mille euros aujourd'hui
ça doit être gérée par un responsable
technique identifié parce que nous
proposons c'est de c'est pareil
effectivement l'activité associative de
l'activité agricole viticole et
commercial l'idée ça serait
effectivement soin de confier on a fermé
par exemple personnes physiques par bail
à plus ou moins long terme la
responsabilité de l'exploitation
viticole et de la commercialisation de
ses produits
ça peut être aussi la création d'une
société civile qui pourrait
effectivement avec le gérant qui
pourrait gérer
cette affaire est 6ème à l'île de ré
c'est sûr dès à présent sur l'idée de
distinguer l'exploitante agricole de
l'exploitant commercial dans son
activité sans paraître imprudente
c'est pas le même métier c'est l'option
enregistreur j'avais quand même la
composition de créer un jardin de
conditions qui sera celle élargi pour
travailler sur ce sujet là pas prendre
de décision aujourd'hui pour demande
aujourd'hui c'est une blague
autorisation le monde a un mandat pour
pour faire les démarches nécessaires
aucune décision naturellement on sera
triste
or l'assemblée générale c'est beau c'est
tout blanc ou un peu là mais c'est qu'on
n'est qu'un accord tard un bruit mais
celle là regrette rien je ne sais plus
chou fleur
tout le monde sait que denis voudrait
bien revenir à la vie oui mais moi je ne
sais pas plus oui oui sinon je ne sais
pas qui peut le terreau est à faire ou
pas et je crois que ça marche je reste
je m'en fous 2 qu'est ce que tu penses
de la séparation du côté vignoble et du
côté commercial
[Musique]
lavigne ne quittera pas de sitôt la
vallée le vignoble a pu renaître porté
par un engagement collectif
mais cet engagement s'est épuisée au fil
des années aujourd'hui il va falloir
trouver ensemble un équilibre entre
patients et gestion pour que le rêve
reste réalité est que jamais ne meurt le
serment de charles
[Musique]
il fallait pas commencé tout petit plus
à du béton rodez dans l'inconnu on
s'enfonce l'image qui gagne sa dann au
musée du supérieur ou dans content de
gagner le bon sens bien dedans je gagne
et que vous servent au financement donc
par exemple à noter le balcon ballesta
bonnes idées j'en évidence haletant mano
des nouvelles au chômage us temps aux
dépens des bilans sanguins sauver la
balle et stoppe aussi détendu comme a
dopé les valeurs humanistes heures
tandis qu'on devine mal dames de
handball l'arrêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]